a lifetime has passed since the horrific  events of Taco Tuesday our lives send it  into chaos this new life has toughened  and hardened two copies please  one black one with just a touch of cream  in 25 sugars  well toughened last of us I wake up in  the morning morning good morning super  babies and it you've gotta stop  pretending everything is awesome it  isn't yeah I get it  and that's why I've cultivated a totally  hard-edged side that's super tough and  Oh something new  what is it up to but that beat is pretty  fresh  [Music]  [Music]  the placket knows our every move weird  right special this guy was a fierce  warrior  okay well technically I did the warrior  stuff so you fought and masterbuilt and  hit but and then the hapless male was  the leader here well  [Music]  hang on to your fronds planty we're  going to save Lucy and all of the other  people who were captured  [Music]  behold the sISTAR sister do not give her  the satisfaction of wooing this  [Music]